you
[Music]
hi everyone my name is Brandon Lewinsky
and I'm a graduate student here at MIT
now the presentation that you're
watching was created by an organization
here at MIT called earth DNA but it's
gonna be shared with high school
students all around the country and so
I'm really excited to be sharing it with
you guys welcome this talk is gonna have
some audience interaction so to get
everybody warmed up please just yell out
your own name on three ready one two
three
nice to meet you like I said I'm Brandon
now in this talk we're gonna cover four
things the truth the consequences the
myths in the future and I want to start
with a truth in particular let's review
the science of what's happening we'll go
through it slowly in 1896 a scientist
discovered the greenhouse effect can
somebody here tell me what the
greenhouse effect is does anybody here
know yes
they're cool it's part of the songs as
part of the Earth's atmosphere that
keeps our temperature warm and normal
okay anybody else
what is the greenhouse effect yes go
ahead
after it's retracted something called
radiative forcing and so some for a lot
of gases in the atmosphere like nitrogen
the sunrays just pass right through but
bird a select few like water and carbon
dioxide that absorb infrared light and
then for red spectrum and then that
drops eat the answer fantastic you must
know your climate science but that's
exactly right and the basic idea is that
some gases in our atmosphere trap heat
and you can see here how light from the
Sun hits the earth it gets converted
into heat and it gets trapped underneath
this atmospheric blanket we emit these
greenhouse gases by burning fossil fuels
for transportation and electricity
things like driving flying air
conditioning these all emit greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere as we burn
fossil fuels like oil gas and coal
greenhouse gas concentrations rise you
can see here that since 2005 the amount
of carbon dioxide one of the main
greenhouse gases has increased steadily
here's that same graph since 1700 you
can see the industrial revolution
happening in 1760 and shortly thereafter
we start to see this increase in the
amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere here's the last 800,000 years
now notice in the last 800,000 years the
maximum carbon dioxide level has been
300 parts per million three hundred
thousand years ago is the oldest Homo
sapiens fossil that's us the Industrial
Revolution happened in 1760 a little
under 300 years ago and here's where we
are now atmospheric greenhouse gases
have spiked
as humans emit more greenhouse gases our
atmosphere traps more heat and the earth
gets warmer you can see here the global
temperature anomaly from NASA over time
it starts with lots of blues and reds
meaning things are pretty normal but as
time goes on from 1950 to today it gets
redder and redder and redder that's
that's Earth warming to 0.82 degrees
Celsius above normal or 1.5 degrees
Fahrenheit now I know what you're
thinking I know what you're thinking who
cares about 1.5 degrees Fahrenheit
that's like nothing and I can barely
even feel it well to answer this
question we have to talk about the
consequences climate change already
affects us whether it's through
wildfires in California or flooding in
the Midwest or hurricanes on the East
Coast the effects of climate change are
already here heat waves floods and other
disasters are becoming more frequent you
can see the recorded natural disasters
per year has skyrocketed since the 1960s
in Boston the city is already planning
sea walls because of more intense and
frequent flooding we are already doing
these things in other words cities must
spend your parents tax money on climate
adaptations instead of schools transit
and hospitals unusual weather also
affects food by 2030 a drought could
double the price of corn and maybe you
don't like corn but I bet you like
chicken or fish which are both raised on
corn feed or maybe you like high
fructose corn syrup in cereal or bread
the point is corn isn't a lot of foods
and bicycling crop growth climate change
limits food access of course it's not
just corn either but at any rate climate
change also effects water this woman
migrated over 150 miles because of a
drought by 2050 the UN projects 200
million environmental migrants these are
people who leave their homes because of
changes in the environment and my
question to you is this
in recent migrant crises thousands of
refugees created turmoil in Europe and
America what happens when millions of
people move north in search of food
water and safety
can we handle that I'm not sure even the
US military refers to climate change as
a threat multiplier because it makes
every bad situation worse and by the way
the Pentagon has released reports about
climate change under both Democratic and
Republican administrations this is not a
partisan issue these problems are not
just in the future either they're
happening right now the current species
extinction rate is 1,000 times higher
than normal if pollinators go so do we
there's no more crops left we're on
track for 1 million species extinctions
and here's what just one of those looks
like
we could live more sustainably so why
don't we to really understand this we
have to talk about the myths and I want
to set the stage with a game called
Commons so at this point I want
everybody to form groups of five and
count off from one to five go ahead and
sit in a circle you guys can stand up
form groups I'll give you a second to to
make this happen it might be easier for
people in the front row to kind of move
to turn your chairs to face the back
because we're gonna be sitting in a
circle cool okay and everybody count off
from one to five within your groups
there's everybody count it off we get to
go okay so you're gonna all start a pond
with twenty fish this is your ponds
carrying capacity your goal at the end
of the game the winner is the person in
the room with the most fish and remember
you win as an individual not as a group
here's how the game actually works each
round every person in your group will
take between one and four fish you have
to take at least one but you can't take
more than four after each round your
pond will be restocked by doubling the
number of fish without exceeding 20 so
four fish becomes eight nine fish
becomes 18 10 fish or more brings the
pond back to 20 does that make sense for
the group of four in the back your
carrying capacity is actually gonna be
four times the number of people in your
group so you're gonna have 16 and so all
the same rules apply where if you double
the number of fish at 8 or higher you'll
go back to 16 you will never have a pond
with 20 fish in it does that make sense
to the group before great don't eat the
goldfish yet and if you have allergies
don't eat the goldfish at all so if
everybody could send person number one
up to the front I can hand you guys
goldfish
great so everybody should have a pond
and a restock supply and can everybody
just make sure that you have the right
number of fish in your pond so it's four
times the number of people in your group
everybody just make sure everybody good
okay you guys have 30 seconds to discuss
strategy starting now
[Music]
round one take turns going clockwise
starting with player three you have 60
seconds
go ahead and restock your pawns you have
30 seconds to do this each time you'll
play four rounds everybody good I'm
gonna go ahead and skip round two
starting with player two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
round three take turns
starting with player four
[Laughter]
does anybody need more time I'm gonna go
ahead and skip again go ahead and
restock everybody good final round
start with player 3
[Music]
[Music]
everybody said anybody need more time
cool let's do one last round just for
fun so who still has fish in their pond
cool okay so we're actually doing this
sometimes we don't go ahead and restock
your ponds you guys have 30 seconds
[Music]
are you guys all set so you guys are
restocked cool all right I'm just gonna
go ahead and skip ahead final round for
real this time take turns going
clockwise starting with player number
one all right is everybody good cool all
right
so who won raise your hand if you have
more than 10 fish I'm sorry go ahead and
count your fish first and then raise
your hand if you have more than 10 cool
yeah okay only two people have more than
10 three people okay more than 11 fish
okay so you guys each have 12 or more do
have 13 or more fish 14 or more fish 15
or more fish how many do you have 15
congratulations to the winner great
okay awesome okay so so talk to me
why was Commons hard what was hard about
this game you guys can go ahead and yell
it out or raise your hands as you wish
you have to have a strategy that
everyone agrees upon okay anybody else
what was hard about this game go ahead
the thing that was best for the Commons
was the most damaging personally anybody
else yes cool
so you weren't quite sure how long we
were gonna keep going great these are
all good answers and really the core of
this is if everyone acts in their own
interest the pond the Commons dies this
is called the tragedy of the Commons
when anyone can access a limited
resource it runs out roads are another
really good example anybody with a car
can access a road and soon enough
everybody is thinking if these idiots
would just take the bus I could be home
by now can somebody or can anybody else
name some other real-life examples of
Commons think about limited resources
that anyone can access yes go ahead air
say more can you say more about air
pollution yes so anybody can access the
air and therefore anybody can pollute it
great
anybody else why okay wireless internet
say more so if everybody watches Memphis
in HD at the same time nobody so if
everybody watches Netflix in HD then
nobody gets to watch Netflix in HD cuz
you don't have enough bandwidth great
any others let's do one last one any any
takers
yes go ahead office mugs tell me more
about office mugs
great so office mugs are something that
anybody in the office can access but
nobody's incentivized to actually take
care of them great what about this one
earth is a Commons we can all access
earth we're all on it and certainly it's
limited so how do we solve Commons
problems either in the game or in real
life does anybody have any ideas how did
you guys solve it in the game let's
start there
strategize together cool can you be more
specific we talked about how we would be
able to keep the most fish on our plate
earner climb by each just taking two so
you guys you guys all ended up each
taking two not the entire time okay
anybody else why how do we solve Commons
problems either in the game or in real
life what do you guys think
yes God so if some people if some people
took more others would take less great
how did that work not well okay
so it didn't work very well well the
answer is and when we kind of came upon
it already
collective action we have to set rules
in order to solve Commons problems one
example was let's all take two but we
saw in your case that sometimes those
rules get broken that's why climate
change is really hard but at any rate
setting rules for everyone is called
politics setting rules for everyone is
called politics and therefore protecting
the most important comments and
inhabitable earth is political we need
rules there's an issue rules cost money
for example if I can't sell my products
because I emit carbon to make them I
lose money and that's not acceptable to
me so now we can answer the question why
haven't we done anything and the answer
is no one wants rules limiting carbon
but especially not fossil fuel groups
who emit more than anyone you can see
here carbon dioxide emissions by sector
residential and commercial industry
transportation agriculture and land use
anybody want to guess what that big blue
one is fossil fuels energy oil gas and
coal yeah
the fossil fuel industry has actually
known about climate change for decades
in 1978 more than 40 years ago Exxon's
senior scientists had this to say
present thinking holds but man has a
time window of five to ten years before
the need for hard decisions regarding
changes and energy strategies might
become critical in other words we have 5
to 10 years to figure out how to get
energy a different way he said that
40 years ago but fossil fuel companies
spread climate myths to the public
including schools
from 2003 to 2010 Koch family
foundations and other fossil fuel groups
gave 558 million dollars to climate
denial organizations and I wish that I
could share more financial data with you
but these groups are secretive and hard
to study in any case the point is this
fossil fuel companies know that rules
will hurt their profits so they spread
myths to the public about climate change
but now you know the truth you know that
climate change is real it's happening
because of us it already affects you it
will only get worse and we haven't done
anything because fossil fuel companies
have lied to us for decades that leaves
us with one final question how do we
shape our future
We Need to Talk and I know that words
may seem inconsequential given some of
the other information I've shared but
words give life to ideas and ideas lead
to change in other words your words
matter I know it may feel awkward but
studies show that teens are actually
great at making parents care about
climate change
be open be gentle be honest you can try
starting with how do you feel about
climate change in fact on the count of
three I want everybody to practice so on
the count of three let's all say how do
you feel about climate change ready one
two three
how do you feel about climate change
it's easy and it works I want to share
one last perspective on why we need to
talk
it's not too late to keep our paradise
but we can't do it without you
I'm gonna leave you guys with a five day
challenge so go ahead and write down the
names of five people you can talk to
about climate change you can do it on
your phones you can do it
on a piece of paper but go ahead and
write down five names of people you can
talk to about climate change each day
each day for the next five days talk
about climate change with someone on
your list and remember time is of the
essence thank you questions
I notice the station in reforestation
for the large solution to a lot of the
solutions our collective based and by
the way I'll be sending out a handout to
all of you guys for things you can do
and informational resources that you can
use for after this talk but to answer
your question the main thing that you
can do in your life is actually stop
eating beef cattle have a huge impact on
greenhouse gases because of the methane
they produce and so if you stop eating
beef that's actually the single biggest
contribution you can make within your
personal life obviously if you are able
to drive less fly less that's another
huge one these are all ways that you can
contribute but as we saw a part of the
reason that climate change is such a
tricky problems because we need
everybody to come together we need wind
farms we need afforestation as you
mentioned we need other kinds of
renewable energy resources but in your
personal life don't eat beef talk about
climate change and fly less are the top
three
yes go ahead we talk a lot about fossil
fuels and transportation and flying and
things like that and same with beef we
care a lot about that and now people are
starting to hear more about plastics
which is a use of fossil fuels but
there's a lot of fossil fuel uses that
are huge like in manufacturing processes
and things where we could buy from
companies who use less fossil fuels but
it's really hard for us to find
information about that is there
for the resource for that I haven't seen
any but I can follow up with you so I
can send you something after along with
the handouts I'll do the best I can
paradise he must protect nature or the
Celtic let's talk how do you think you
should be that's a good question so the
question is how should we talk to our
parents about climate change you know
your parents better than I do and that's
part of why it turns out that teenagers
and kids are actually so good at this
messenger matter is much more than
message when it comes to climate change
and so if you come to your parents and
say this is important to you I think
that's enough to start a conversation
don't attack people including your
parents that tends not to be super
helpful to quote one of the professor's
here at MIT research shows that showing
research to people doesn't work and so
if you can if you can talk to your
parents from a personal perspective and
what it means to you that I think is the
best way to start these conversations
stories and personal impacts work a lot
better than graphs and data yeah does
that answer your question yeah cool
thanks anybody else
awesome oh yes one more so what did you
come up against someone who it's not I
that's a really hard question the
question is how do we talk to people who
are truly convinced that climate change
is not real if it's a stranger honestly
you're probably not gonna have much of a
shot at convincing them as I said
messenger matters more than message and
there's not you don't really have the
credibility with that person to sway
their opinion on something that they
hold so dearly but again if it's a
relative start the conversation with
what climate change means for you and as
I said I'll send out resources from NASA
and from NOAA and from a bunch of other
very credible institutions that you can
look at to see more information and and
why our models work and how we know all
of the things that we know about climate
change and of course you're more than
welcome
in fact encouraged to share that with
your relatives and friends and so on
does that answer your question thank you
do we have no yes in the back
my question is really more formed than
anything whenever whenever you ask the
question about greenhouse gas effect is
there like a number in your head that
you have before like you'll ask a
certain number of people before you just
move on for the sake of time cool I want
to hold with just two questions for
afterwards but does anybody have any
questions within the scope of the
presentation anybody else
like saying like the data are you
kidding like where you're getting this
information from this bias if you look
elsewhere you'll see different data and
then I just leave it and over time they
start to see that and like I've started
to change their minds about it that's a
really good point so don't expect for a
single conversation to completely change
somebody's mind that's really hard and
unlikely but over the course of of these
conversations I think you'll be
surprised and pleased at how successful
you'll be at at changing the minds of
people that are close to you cool thank
you guys so much for coming I really
appreciate it and we can answer some
logistical questions but we don't need
to record that
[Applause]
you